let's face it even in today's rapidly
diversifying ev market whenever someone
is talking about an electric car you can
bet that what they're thinking about is
a tesla however despite this lasting
fame and unparalleled dominance a bunch
of the traditional brands that have for
years been jealous of tesla seem to be
catching up and by far the most imposing
threat to tesla's dominance has been the
volkswagen group who with their brand
armada of companies like porsche audi
and skoda have actually not only caught
up to tesla but have beat them in one of
the world's three major ev markets and
so to understand how this massive shift
came what caused it and what's in store
for the future keep watching the video
till the end because we'll dive into
everything from the history to sales
numbers to potential outcomes without
further ado let's jump right in to start
with let's take a brief look at the ev
industry in general in 2020 out of all
the ev sales worldwide tesla sold a
solid 500 000 evs which gives them a
market share of just sixteen percent and
as impressive as that is that is
actually down one percent from 2019 by
comparison volkswagen sold about 422 000
vehicles in 2020 which is more than
twice as many vehicles that they sold in
2019 and remember tesla has held the
entire ev industry in its hands for an
entire decade compare that to volkswagen
who have only just started to take the
matter seriously the result of that
aggressiveness is nowhere clearer than
in the fourth quarter of 2020 where the
company actually defied all odds and
beat tesla in total sales selling a very
impressive 191
000 while tesla just managed 183 000 and
while overall in purely electric sales
for example not including plug-in
hybrids volkswagen's market share is
still less than half of what tesla is
enjoying right now over time their
position is looking a lot less permanent
and that idea is further corroborated by
one crucial piece of information
europe
you see as of right now there are three
markets for electric vehicles those
being north america china and europe
while in america tesla is obviously
dominating by a considerable margin and
in china regional companies are grabbing
a foothold in europe the situation has
gone where no one would have expected it
to because as of this moment volkswagen
is actually the single biggest seller of
evs in all of europe in a recent report
by dan levy for credit suisse he writes
that in europe volkswagen has climbed to
the top position in the all-electric car
market in 2020 with a 24 market share up
from 13 last year by comparison tesla
has gone from 29 in 2019 to 13
in 2020 what this shows is that under
the right conditions it can take only a
year to completely switch the tides of
an entire multinational market and while
in terms of value volkswagen still
remains only about one-fifth of tesla's
size in terms of market cap 154 billion
dollars versus 678 billion dollars i
think we can make a pretty good case for
a major change to be entirely possible
in the coming years and now that we've
established that let's look at some of
the reasons why we think that it's not
only a possibility but a likelihood for
that to happen first of all we have one
of the most surprising motivators to
volkswagen's electrification the
dieselgate scandal you see while the
march towards electric cars was
inevitable for all big companies
volkswagen actually ended up getting a
more immediate incentive in 2015 which
made them make electrification their
prime objective because as it turns out
back then the us environmental
protection agency uncovered proof that
the company had been rigging its diesel
vehicles to cheat emissions tests in the
states and that made the company not
only face massive fines and public
ridicule but it also made the investors
realize that in an increasingly
environmentally cautious world the only
way to survive was electric and secondly
and more practically this scandal came
with a sudden change in leadership when
the then head martin winkerton was
dismissed after a few hasty shifts the
company landed in the hands of its
latest ceo herbert dice who among other
things is one of the most staunch
supporters of going electric what all of
that means is that now we have a
well-established company that has the
means motivation and leadership that all
point towards a stronger ev program and
now you might be asking how that gives
them an edge over tesla well the answer
lies in the second edge volkswagen has
over tesla
scaling and experience david traynor ceo
of new constructs which is an investment
research firm in nashville has said that
by far volkswagen has at least one big
advantage over tesla scale because let's
face it as successful and recognizable
as elon's tesla is it has nowhere near
the production capability factories
workforce resources and experience that
is required to make a properly
mass-produced vehicle according to an
article from credit suisse they say that
they believe tesla has yet to prove it
can produce vehicles anywhere near the
scale of the incumbents who have proven
they can switch their internal
combustion engine production capacity
over to make evs it is in fact for this
reason that the company has been facing
delays left and right for all sorts of
cars from their flagship model s to
their supposed mass market model 3 and
while there are plans already in motion
to remedy that with the construction of
many new factories worldwide for now
volkswagen easily edges out tesla and
their ability to make cars make them
consistently and most importantly our
next point make them cheap costs
for the longest time the biggest barrier
between mass ev adoption has been the
cost of owning a vehicle because with
the average cost exceeding 70 000 for
the earlier years of the industry the
largest portion of the market simply
couldn't afford to buy one however as
the technology has developed and
adoption has increased the costs have
decreased significantly and it's one of
the places where companies like
volkswagen can really land some solid
blows against tesla and it's because of
that by being such large and
well-established companies brands like
volkswagen have an automatic and large
cost advantage since they've already
built and fully staffed their factories
all the while tesla is having to manage
not only existing production but also
expansion all from the same products as
a result where tesla's lowest offerings
are for now the model 3 and y their over
55 000 asking price is always going to
be higher than competitors and in this
case volkswagen while that has always
been the case combine this advantage
with the last one and we have a good
case for why volkswagen is meeting such
massive success and that's without even
discussing the next big advantage they
have
a more diverse market
now while we have used the name
volkswagen in this video it's not just
cars with a volkswagen badge that we're
talking about because you see the
volkswagen group is actually a huge
conglomerate of many car companies and
includes the likes of audi porsche skoda
lamborghini bentley and many others
because of that they face a key
advantage against tesla they can target
a far greater and far more diverse
audience with their evs in comparison to
the standard tech enthusiast that tesla
generally targets think about it
companies like porsche are already
getting support from sports enthusiasts
while audi has one of the longest
legacies in the luxury segment all the
while the vw brand itself covers all
mid-range and low-cost vehicles all in
all this level of exposure and diversity
means that once they're making
sufficiently large numbers of evs from
each company they'll be able to sell to
you anywhere from college graduates
looking for a volkswagen gulf to the ceo
looking to be chauffeured in an audi and
that brings us to the final and most
crucial point the one without which all
the prior ones are meaningless the cars
themselves
now let's face the elephant in the room
the fact that all we have mentioned
besides the incentives are not things
that are exclusive to volkswagen so why
are they the only ones who seem to be
making a difference well we'll tell you
why no one else knows how to even make a
good ev it's simple honestly tesla has
had the entire ev market as its own
testing ground for a decade and what
they've lacked in industrialization and
scaling they have certainly made up for
by having the most effective cars out
there and so when during the last few
years other companies have tried to
compete they've simply been unable to
come up with an answer to tesla's
expertise that is unless your volkswagen
because according to ubs a swiss
investment bank and one of the biggest
investors in any industry worldwide they
believe that the id3 volkswagen's
cheapest and most popular ev is the only
offering that can compete with tesla in
fact a detailed analysis by the
investing agency showed that the german
hatchback not only matched up to the
model 3 but even outperformed the
best-selling ever in several areas part
of the reason was the meb platform a
modular car platform for manufacturing
electric cars developed by volkswagen
for easy scaling and implementation into
all sorts of formats and models is fully
cost competitive with tesla and reaches
best in class energy density efficiency
and scalability and if that wasn't
already praise enough for the automaker
the analysis called the car the most
credible ev effort for any legacy auto
company so far and well taking a look
side by side it's not hard to see why
they were so impressed the id3 which as
we mentioned is a four-door hatchback
basically mirroring the gulf is a direct
competitor to the model 3 by tesla and
has practically the same range capacity
and performance for the price of only
forty thousand dollars compared to tesla
whose prices have recently shot up to
sixty thousand dollars as a result it's
no shock that the release of this car
was the reason for the uncanny boom in
sales that we saw in europe and while it
didn't make that big a ripple in the
other markets volkswagen has an answer
for that too since in september 2020
they released the id4 an suv which they
believe is far more attractive in the
north american and chinese markets and
wouldn't you know it it has since become
volkswagen's top selling ev overall add
to that the company's future plans to
start making batteries in-house with
plans to operate six battery cell
factories in europe by the end of the
decade as well as a plan to have nearly
40 000 public charging stations
worldwide by 2025 and it's not hard to
see why the company has a shot at
becoming the biggest ev maker in the
future and while there is still a lot
for the company to face from tackling
weaknesses like software to tesla's own
plans to make a factory in berlin if
there's one thing we can say for sure
it's that the ev world is about to get a
whole lot more interesting and well on
that note we must end today's video i
hope you enjoyed watching it and if you
did be sure to leave a like and
subscribe for more also click this video
to find out how this company backed by
jeff bezos can become tesla's biggest
threat with that take care and i'll see
you guys next time